we have a voicemail number it's 2192
david p last week we received a
voicemail saying before the New England
Patriots defeated the Pittsburgh
Steelers to win the AFC Championship and
go to the Super Bowl to face the Atlanta
Falcons on februari fifth yes thank you
pat we had a voicemail saying it is a
fact a fact that the New England
Patriots are going to lose to the
Pittsburgh Steelers and we said well
it's not really a fact if it's a
prediction predictions aren't fact it's
a fact that you predicted it but the
content of the prediction is not a fact
of course the Patriots won and here is a
caller it's kind of hard to hear him
because he's calling from a cell phone
clearly was not the best connection
suggesting that it was an alternative
fact that that caller presented to us
take a listen to this hey still is one
they still on the Patriots lost yeah
that's just an alternative fact right
don't learn Patriots I'm not going to
the Super Bowl to steal yo you may have
fast that I have alternative facts oh
yeah Ashton significantly alternative
fact is relating to the result of
football games just just this is all a
joke but just to remind you of one thing
this is sort of like when you have one
person on TV who says climate science is
real and then another person who says
climate science is not real and then
it's presented as if it's fifty-fifty as
if hey it's just alternative facts when
of course the science is like 99 to 1 it
actually reminds me of that luckily this
collar is doing us a good service by
doing some friendly trolling and allows
you to make that point on the bonus show
today the British government has lost a
brexit Court ruling us solar power is
now employing more people than oil coal
and gas combined and this relates to a
lot about what our energy policy should
be and also what I hope will be the
final update on david pakman show coffee
blend we are getting to the end of the
line with the preparations for david
pakman show Koffee david pakman.com
slash membership that's the only way
that you can get access to the bonus
show it is instant access and you can
use coupon code I voted 17 to get a
discount off of your membership this is
viewer supported media
never been more important than in the
era of Trump